hey what's up beautiful babies welcome
to another episode of get close I am
your co-host
Geo
I said Geo in my brain and I was already
I was ready to kick it off to you wow
how do you do that you can do that I I
mean yeah right now tell me one sentence
every other word omit okay hi Geo
Ascent it's like a real sentence that is
hi I'm Geo not a first grade sentence
like this okay dude I was trying to pop
my car into the transmission but the
transmission got stuck in park I looked
through the rear view mirror and I found
I was stuck in a ditch like a real
sentence what the [__] okay
oh [__] okay
um so I woke up so I up
seven I can't do it that's so hard I
would do that so that was that was
technically like a brain fart then that
was yeah absolutely a brain fart like I
wish I could do it on command like um
back in high school yeah I was such a
[__] loser in high school like I'm so
sorry if you were the recipient of this
stupid ass prank but we would obviously
get high like me and my girlfriends we
would get high one of us or one of my
girlfriends had um she had a car I
thought if you got high you're not a
loser in high school
well in retrospect I see myself now as a
loser back then I was still kind of a
loser oh really I was never like really
cool I thought only the cool kids did
drugs back then I guess so I mean I
guess it depends on what side of the
coin you're on right like what team
you're on because if you're on team
studious you're looking at all the
[__] Stoners as like losers because
they're not like prepping for SATs and
then like setting their career up that's
right it depends on how you define loser
exactly
um
yeah we would get high and then
obviously you have to order food you
like you get the munchies so then we
would go to like a drive-through like
McDonald's or something and then I would
order and then I would pretend like my
voice would cut out
so I'd be like hi um yeah and I would
like fries on the side and other
girlfriends
and I was like I said yes yeah [__]
attitude
all right I want to order geez
what a loser right yeah don't you but
yes I would do that that was the extent
of like it's funny what kids do to try
to have fun dude it's funnier to even
see it all over again so like seeing uh
so I could go through it so like
starting from the beginning you know
like his first prank is technically
magic right because he's like look at my
thumb oh or he does this thing where he
like makes his like thumb like extend
but like you can see the whole magic
trick playing out like this yeah and
sometimes this whole thumb comes out
yeah so you should like that or um he's
not really a prankster too much but I
can already just kind of see it
developing into that yeah
um so it just it's so stupid like it's
so such a hypocrite because um when I
was in junior high I was such a uh
a menace
and I remember we used to hang out at
that park outside of our old house and
you remember those teenage kids they
would climb on top of the awning of the
roof okay right where people have the
picnic tables at the park yeah I'm like
what the [__] you [__] scumbags look
at all this [__] property tax you're
just [__] destroying you know how
much money it costs to build this
goddamn you would think that you just
said all of that [__] yeah I was like
and I was like get your ass [__] down
from there you [__] Hooligans I think
I was saying all of that and then when I
was a kid though I would be the first
one like yo you guys need to climb this
[__] you [__] hypocrite [__] why did
that happen
oh what the hypocrite yeah yeah why did
you why don't you revert back to that
and go like oh I know where it's coming
from like why are you the grumpy guy now
I think because I can tell their
intentions
which was what what do you think they're
gonna do kick a [__] hole in the roof
no there's way different intentions so
you know how you could tell when
someone's climbing like on top of those
tunnel slides okay if they're climbing
on top of it there's the oh I'm just uh
I'm I'm gonna be a parkour champion in
the future and just you're just white
like there's that kind of person right
oh I see there's a kind of like I just
gonna go against the [__] culture and
then I'm a [__] anti-guy you know and
he just like you know and he's just kind
of like a scumbag yeah and then there's
people that are like oh like I'm
athletic so we're playing hide and seek
I know people can catch me like there's
so many different intentions yeah when I
saw that guy it was more of a look at me
I'm a [__] douchebag like well yeah
we see it as a douchebag but he's just
saying look at how cool I am yeah like
I'm such a grown-up he's doing it for
clout yeah yeah like he's proving that
he's like an adult amongst kids yeah
because like he's the best if no one was
at the park he wouldn't have done it
yeah and you never had that intention
my friends explored and did things it
was it was because the park was empty
we're not trying to get attention you
know we would just do things because so
I think there was a like we went through
the same actions but I can like real
recognize real you know and honestly and
that is unreal that is unreal yeah okay
that makes sense so that's what you were
like so you weren't grumpy because of
the taxes you were just like I know that
those types yeah [__] that kid I wish I
could teleport into my 12 year old body
or whoop his ass did you were you
whooping ass at 12
I mean again there's a couple scraps
here and there what the [__] you would
definitely wear a menace you were
absolutely a menace people were fighting
all over the place
um sure but that doesn't mean you have
to get involved in it I got into like my
first like real real fist fight
well actually I guess then since I was
six people kick me in the face and I
cried and I ran home but that's not a
real real fist fight you just got
bullied yeah it was a real strike
absolutely the kid was younger than me
but bigger than you said right yeah
that's the the sister who was like in uh
no no oh my God I'm gonna ask you a lot
but but this kid kicked me like full
it's not like a tussle or like a little
shove match it was a straight up bow and
then my lips just
like it was like my first fist fight you
know like do you remember what happened
what Set It Off
um I think it was like Hey I do karate
and I was like well I do kung fu and
then we just started kicking each other
like maybe air kicking and then he
kicked me in the mouth
and it was real is he mad
no it just it escalated
it could have it could have escalated or
it could have just been like hey I did
kung fu I did Karate bam and I run home
oh so that's not real real that's an
accident
no it was real
so like there was bad intention behind
that yeah he was loading up for the
second kick
you know what so like this is what's
funny
um so back in the day when I would hear
all your stories as like a kid and all
that
um and how your parents like like would
discipline you and like how they would
talk to you and just how your teachers
were with you
I would absolutely empathize and I was
like [__] man like why one I would see
pictures of you as a little kid and I'm
like but he's so cute how can you do
that and then two I'm like but he's a
little kid like come on now like adults
you [__] up you know better you cannot
do this to a kid control your [__]
self
now your Offspring yeah
he's five years old yeah he's cute isn't
he and he's evolved significantly in
terms of his personality his character
his quirks
um his his curiosity
has grown exponentially from four and a
half to now about like five and a half
so this past year with him
I've seen such a different side of taika
he's a [__] Menace
he's a [__] Menace he's been
diagnosed with ADHD
um
um super [__] smart he's very curious
he colors outside the box
figuratively and literally
um
he is just out of [__] control and I
can see how people get annoyed of him
[__] fast yeah
he's my son and I love him and you're
annoyed of him
um I don't know if annoy is a correct
word because I feel like when you say
annoyed there's some sort of like get
away from me like you're just a [__]
pest oh you just hate him then I don't
hate him
I'm not annoyed by him nor do I hate him
he just wears me out yeah he will not
the only one
you [__] 100 wear me out outside of
the best bedroom but when we're outside
but when we have sex
um I'm well preserved so this is our
code word for meditation
so now that I have a glimpse of what I
believe you were as a kid I absolutely
empathize with everyone else with
everyone else because you're not knowing
taika yes because I know the intentions
are good
but you really have to grow up around it
or with him to really understand where
it's coming from because you guys both
don't operate on the normal scale you
can only
um look at those actions with the normal
scale Vision do you know what I mean
like like because I don't even want to
call it normal because that's not normal
but the the majority of us who don't
have ADHD or who don't don't have that
same amount of curiosity or energy
um we operate a certain way yeah and
it's usually in a straight line so like
we can predict if if if this kid walks
up to the side of the table or like if
the kid stands up on the table there are
only so many outcomes he's gonna knock
everything over and spill it or he's
gonna like not pay attention fall off
and hurt himself right like we can
predict the Behavior now if someone like
Bart or a taika get on the table if
you're not keen to it like the thought
process like you're only going to prep
yourself for those two possible major
Inc outcomes when we in reality when
dealing with a taika or a Bart there are
a hundred different things that can
happen they're gonna to turn on the
spigot spray everyone that's sitting
there they're going to get a knife and
try to see how far they can throw it to
see if it's like what they watch in the
movies if if it goes to the drywall or
not it's gonna stick like there's just
so many outcomes and someone that's not
used to that and only
um interacts with a Bart or a taika from
time to time they just think it's all
done with malice intent
and the word that best describes taika
and you as a kid yeah okay sure
are you ready for it is this one word
okay Australian
he's Australian that's all it is
okay so pretend I don't pretend I don't
hear the thought process so it sounds
funny right Australian
well Australian by itself is not very
funny it's just no but it sounds funny
to describe them okay but like
all the Australian to Australians
if you grew up Australian so he's
Australian to Australians oh no no no
he's one he's one of them
okay so you're are you gonna like if
you're Australian right if your
nationality is Australian
but you didn't grow up Australian you
might think he's wild too
but if you're Australian like a real
Australian Australian to you can you
explain that a Crocodile Dundee
[__] Okay so someone who's not
even so the outskirts of Australia then
so like this you know how many resorts I
love how you just listen you know how
many resorts we've been to wait wait no
no no you know how many results you've
been to
um I guess a bunch okay every single
Resort and every other country we go to
which families are the ones where the
kids tally whackers are hanging out okay
fine Australians exactly yeah they run
around naked so the ones that are like
they grew up on the beach or they're
just outdoorsy they just have like this
extra like almost skate-like Vibe like
like everything's cool let's just [__]
around we're just boys being boys
they're like the most well we've met an
Australian and you know a couple
Australians that didn't fit that what
you're talking about didn't grow up
Australian they probably grew up [__]
they literally Melbourne or or Sydney or
whatever so that's not all [__] what is
Melbourne Sydney to you then there's
city folks that's that's like grown up
in need
Outback [__] Australian oh I'm
talking about the spirit of Australia
you know like the real Australians the
ones that look at Americans and go man
you guys are [__] [__] I think a
lot of people a lot of different
countries say that about us no a lot of
them think we're Cowboys still a lot of
people think whoa America's wild like UK
look at America like they're wild yeah
them and all their guns they're [__]
wild right and the real Australians are
the ones are like that's the only amount
of guns you have I grew up with 30 way
more guns we've been hunting my whole
life you know and we cook our own food
and we [__] kill [__] born [__]
skin them alive and go surfing or
whatever got it the real Australians you
know okay the real Australians so
they're just really cool people that
just live life yeah boldly like Tim
Kennedy's probably Australian
you know what I mean that's what I'm
talking about like the real Australians
so it's not a personality type it's a
nationality no it's one of those like
what is it called homophones or whatever
the one word can mean a lot of different
things okay and so he's just Australian
about it but isn't homo mean one
what you said homophone homo means the
same oh okay right like homosexual the
same okay okay so homophone probably
means it sounds the same thing oh yeah
sounds the same okay yeah so anyways
um he's just Australian about it and uh
one one quote that I heard from Jordan
Peterson recently that I was like oh wow
like that really hit me in the
was uh he says uh
creatives
by definition
color outside of right yeah they're
wrong right and then so if they color
outside of right the people that are
right will look at them wrong yeah
because people that are right they go in
the straight line like you're talking
about what I'm saying like like 85 like
the standard deviation everyone stays in
here right like 80 90 of the population
stays in here
but the people that are creatives are
always wrong or Australian they're like
that right they're the ones that are
hanging out the back of the pickup truck
when you're driving you're not supposed
to do that you know that kind of stuff
and um
like people like on jackass and stuff
too they're all Australian but
um what he said that hit me was in the
what it hit you in the where's okay what
Jordan Peterson said that hit me was but
it takes a creative to get it perfect
because if you do things right you never
innovate right the cure for cancer the
cure for this AI solar panels
cars even if we stuck to the old days
they're like why would anyone ever need
a car my horse is more reliable in the
car I don't gotta put gas under the
horse right if everyone thought the same
way we would never get it perfect in
advance so it takes creatives and I'm
like oh man like that when it hit me
it hit me in a way where like it
teleported me back to my childhood
because there's a lot of ways where I
was like why are we doing things this
way I know you want me to do it this way
but I feel like there's 10 other ways we
can do it and then I just slowly mold it
into feeding into the system yeah but it
hit me harder when I think about taika
because taika although he is a menace
he's actually so innocent he is he has
no malicious intent
like he doesn't want to hurt anybody he
cares about people's feelings
um so when he's coloring outside of the
lines and you're telling and people tell
me wrong like whether a teacher or a
coach or whatever you're wrong you're
wrong you're wrong he's like well why
what do you mean
you know it's just because like his
brain is so expanded because of his
creative ways he's outside of right yeah
and so I'm like man like I think it's so
damn it you just made it so [__] real
and I was just trying to play Here and
Now I you just made me look like the
[__] bad guy ah
because I what I just say because I was
just saying hi didn't I don't empathize
with you as a kid yeah yeah I just told
you that I [__] up no because
sometimes creatives get it perfect
sometimes emphasis on this sometimes and
right now yeah I'll emphasis on this
sometimes for sure
um but yeah well [__] I can't even
continue my thought what was your
thought that I was empathizing with the
adults or with everyone else because
I've seen it in action through tiger I
mean but I empathize with the adults too
right I help them with homework I help
them with Jiu Jitsu I help him with
stuff
and even though I've been there
you get caught up here I get caught up
in it too because I know it's one of
those things where it's like it's like
having a baby gorilla as a as a pet
you know like he he doesn't mean to like
exert this strength and break every
single like glass valuable that you have
but he's like damn what do I what do I
do like this guy like socked three
computer screens already I gotta replace
all of those and you're like I know one
day he becomes a full-grown grown
gorilla he's gonna be respectful he's
gonna love me he's gonna be the best
protector ever but this journey this
process of maturing
and ripening is [__] difficult [__]
Yeah man
so like so so yes when I was saying that
I empathize with the adults and stuff
um it was partially a joke and I just
wanted to be funny with it yeah um I
know I'm not the comedian so maybe
that's why it wasn't funny
um but there is some truth to that
because like you said 90 of us we live
within these parameters that we
understand that we're like okay these
rules make sense a plus b equals c we
get it but for a creative or someone
with ADHD or someone that's super
curious
um it's more so so like well a to the
square root of two plus b whatever you
know like there's just a different
equation that's happening that still
comes out with the same answer or even a
more specific answer
but for us we're like what the [__] are
you doing that doesn't make any sense
like because we can't think that way so
um now that I'm seeing it happen we've
heard teachers say like oh you know
we're afraid like you know taika's just
so rambunctious or so curious or can't
keep his hands to himself that like kids
right now don't even want to like a lot
of them don't even want to be his friend
um and what I think they say or what
they mean by that because I've been
really paying attention because
obviously I'm not in his classroom
because I can't be
um nor do I want to be but
I am at his practice and with practice
it's just such a concentrated glimpse of
when he does get to interact with his
friends School classmates
um that I see how it starts and then how
it ends up so it'll start like this kids
get so excited to see taika right like
oh taika we want to play with him but
then taika goes into his his mode his
Australian mode
um and then he just kind of goes off the
rails so AKA he's wrong now so he'll be
getting in like people's faces not to be
confrontational but just because that's
how he likes to play like he'll be like
what will you do what are you doing what
are you doing you know he gets like nose
to nose and for a lot of other kids
they're just like whoa what the [__]
dude back off or he just gets Super
Hyper and he's like really really hyper
to her now there they understand okay
it's class time Focus I want to do the
thing and tyco's just blowing kisses at
them they're like come on taika like I
want to work we need to practice because
they understand consequences whereas
taika understands consequences but he's
so out of his body or two in his head
I'm not sure which one that he kind of
forgets that consequences exist because
he's so in the moment so it's not until
we shake him up or we redirect him and
he's like oh [__] I [__] up and he
understands he [__] up but he's so in
the zone he doesn't understand that but
because the kids the all the other kids
do
eventually they want to get away from
him because they're just like he's too
crazy he's going to get me in trouble
I'm not learning I'm not practicing so I
see that every single time with practice
yay taika's here and then towards the
end they're just like dude get away
and I'm like oh I feel so bad but then
at the same time I'm like
but [__] I get it I empathize with them
also because I'm like how do you deal
with that
what's happening I know it's hard
there's no like
it's really hard because he doesn't
really learn the right uh I want to say
right but he doesn't learn the
systemized ways that we have like um one
of the things that we're doing with like
him is reading right and I think every
kid that understands like phonetically
how to put a word together
um like let's say You're supposed to
like say caterpillar
right like
yeah you send out every letter pillar
right and then a normal kid will uh will
will do that and then they'll understand
okay cool now I can read caterpillar I
can read any other word that has like a
cat and whatever that kind of stuff
right
but taika
um through our psych evaluation with the
with the PhD
they realized he's actually very good at
decoding which is something that I I was
also really really good at so when he
looks at a word and sometimes you look
at him and you're like he looks at a
word and he's like oh caterpillar you're
like wow that is insane you could read
like a was a cat or a pillar like four
syllable word at five insane right you
give them something like a variant maybe
capillary or something and then the
other kid that could go
capillary
you look at that word and just say
caterpillar too and then now you're like
oh wait what the this guy's just
guessing now and it's because he already
learned how to read in his own way and
to the outside person it seems like
memorization but it's not he's at it's
actually recognitions and the reason why
I can relate to that is how I was able
to learn fast was through that through
that too it's almost like reading
Chinese so he's not looking at letters
as if it's pieced together he probably
sees a c a line and then the picture no
no and two L's and he's like oh anything
with the c and a line at two L's that's
caterpillar you know so if he sees
another one like is it what you say you
he knows the a he knows the Z he's
figuring out the middle it probably is
and then so he just sees things and he's
like like Chinese there's no logical way
to teach Chinese you know there's no
phonetic it's not like Korean circle
square this is this sound it's literally
every memorization every symbol is its
own thing yeah so if you know a thousand
words it's not because you could put a
thousand words together and it's not
coming from an alphabet of 26 it's
because you memorize a thousand words so
he would actually be very good at
Chinese because he could just see things
and recognize it like that stamp for
what it is yeah and because of that I'm
like damn it's really hard to teach so
how I've been trying to teach is I
understand that decoding superpower that
he has but I still want him to learn the
right way because that's how you or the
standardized way yeah because that's how
you learn this language yeah but he
might not be good at this language
um he might be more inclined to another
language but he's in America so he has
to learn this language so I'm trying to
help him like almost Mr Miyagi reverse
it like paint the fence then learn how
to block yeah so if he can memorize like
he knows a lot of bunch of big words he
does Caterpillar Forest whatever I'm
like okay cool you know these and you
memorize it good keep memorizing them
while I still teach you these baby steps
of how to say cat or dog or whatever
yeah
it's been um
it's been such a learning curve for me
on two levels
so the first one is because actually
three levels so right now he's five
we're doing a lot of homework the first
level that I'm learning is through his
five-year-old lens
right so I just have to go back to what
I recall as being a kid and like going
back to those lessons can even remember
when you're five
I barely remember when I was five
vaguely yeah five yeah I just remember
red scissors right hand green scissors
left hand yeah no I remember and eating
flowers
[__] weirdo we ate flowers in the
back because they were sweet it was like
these purple ones and you pulled out the
middle and you tasted it was really
sweet ew how dirty
so yeah that's for Slayer that I'm
learning is just kind of reverting back
to that and then like trying to
constantly remind myself that he doesn't
know this right because to us because we
already know it we're kind of stupid to
the idea of not even understanding it
because logically we've found the steps
right so like reading for example cat we
understand the C Sound is the a sound is
ah and then the t is T right so we know
that it's just like it should be easy
cat so I have to remind myself that he
just learned ABC even exists
so taking it that far back so that's
what I mean by I'm learning that he's
five in what he's learning so that's the
first layer the second layer is now
um um adding the fact that he has ADHD
and then bringing him back so allowing
him to get his wiggles out enough so
where I'm also trying to think about
okay I can allow him to do this here but
what will his teachers allow this
Behavior to live in the classroom so I
have to think about that the last one is
I have to think about is
um I am fortunately from what I recall
and sorry family if this is incorrect
but from what I recall I didn't have
this type of one-on-one attention
you know so I've just seen in this short
amount of time how much you and I have
devoted time to like really sit there
and walking through every single lesson
and read with him we do review sessions
in the morning before he goes to school
we do homework at night so he's getting
a lot of
um work time
or a lot of practice
um so now going to that and being like
holy [__] like there's a lot of
repetition it's a lot of patience at
least for me it feels like it takes a
lot of patience because it's like I need
to slow everything down and I need to go
like okay we got to repeat this over and
over and over again so it's such a huge
learning curve right now where I'm going
like holy [__] how do you do this with
multiple children or how do you do this
with like multiple children and a job or
how do you do this as a single parent
like I'm just like how does anyone
[__] have
the knowledge the patience the know-how
the maturity like what the [__] it's
crazy because it's um it literally feels
like
we're playing craps
and then we cropped out
with the cute kid what do you mean so
like on our side right I see us how much
effort we put into it with him and every
single aspect from his nutrition to
sleeping working Jiu Jitsu with them
sleeping making sure we have lots of
CUNY time with him speaking talking to
him about what's going on at school all
that stuff right yeah we're programming
this little computer and we see this guy
that's like barely like hovering where
people don't hate his guts he's really
he's more so on the like I'm right on
the cusp of you're about to hate me okay
and then I see the parents that come in
drop off three kids straight to their
phone and kids are Stellar they just
naturally do it the parent does zero
parenting and the kids just in their DNA
it's like this the parents just rolling
dice
sevens and elevens all day baby sevens
and elevens and I'm like
I was like crapping all day you know
we're playing roulette and it's just
hitting double zero zero and then that
person's just hitting the red all day
long I'm like what the [__] this is
crazy it is crazy because it's not the
parenting effort that adds to the result
you know I've seen zero parenting effort
you can't see what's going on at home
though I could already know that type
I've been around that I've been around
that you know I've been around my mom my
mom's friends that like Taiwanese
lifestyle I know that that's the
Taiwanese lifestyle
there are zero emotional connection okay
because where's the other connect is it
just all just based on achievements
academics yeah I'm not your friend I'm
your parent
um you know eat or I'm gonna whoop your
ass now you're done go
like if I'm if they're like that's
probably why they're Stellar they're
seeing karaoke at home
you're measuring Stellar based on
achievements so of course it makes sense
but are they going to be Stellar with
emotions
you know what I mean like are they gonna
be emotionally intelligent or are you
there's someone [__] them up with
emotions I'm not saying any of that I'm
just saying like we have to look at the
whole picture we can't just look at what
like saying we crapped out with taika
and I know you don't mean that in a bad
way obviously yeah but what I'm saying
is like we work Jiu Jitsu moves at home
yeah and in Jiu Jitsu he's not even
doing this yeah he doesn't give a [__]
the other kids are probably doing Kumon
at home and they come and whatever
they're learning in Jiu Jitsu is
sticking into doing it yeah well I don't
know I don't know if that's a fair
um I don't think that's a fair example
I I think that's the truest example I
don't think so it's like having a
Rottweiler because we haven't tried so
much to train them yeah [__] to
Apples though okay you know what I mean
like
um so for example with those three kids
that you're talking about I know who
you're referring to specifically oh yeah
I do
um and you have to remember they're a
group of three right so I see them
rolling with each other all the time
there's other kids in that group though
there's a lot of other kids that I see
that parents don't
um engage yeah out of okay put it this
way out of all the parents yeah but they
don't need to engage because the kid's
doing he's following
suits like this pay attention out of all
the exactly out of all the 40 parents
there
let's say we did a parent Jiu Jitsu
tournament
who do you think's winning
the parents Jiu Jitsu tournament yeah
what do you mean like what answer you
like I don't know I don't know how how
much clearer I can get we do have
parents uh-huh Jiu Jitsu tournament with
all the parents that we see there okay
every single day are we included in that
of course yeah who's winning
um
I mean a lot of those parents also do
Jiu Jitsu no you and I are winning
you're beating all the girls I'm beating
all the dudes
probably not in Jiu Jitsu we know more
Jiu Jitsu than all the parents there
okay
we're the we're the ones that help these
kids or help our kid a lot
the other parents they don't even know
what the [__] going on they're just
gossiping on the side kids crushing
that's what I'm saying that I realized
in parenting
there's it can be like Michael Jordan's
kid might not be the best basketball
player and I'm learning that firsthand
where Michael Jordan's parents maybe
didn't even give a [__] about basketball
and they created a Michael Jordan you
know so that's why I just realized we're
like I'm like well that but you're
missing the key point there what
um that we gave too much [__] no is
that with Michael Jordan example those
kids want to be there right so Michael
Jordan gravitated towards basketball
naturally I don't know how do you not
know that
so Michael Phelps apparently got put
into swimming because he had 80 crazy
ADHD and I was the only thing that could
wear his ass out
so I don't know if he wanted to be there
or if his mom forced his ass um and they
just so happened to have size 19 feet
yeah yeah building flippers yeah yeah
okay well I guess we don't know
um in terms of what you're saying about
taika specifically because that I do
know and I'm not talking about the
champion of the world there's kind of a
couple things working against us uh
which I don't even think is a big deal
yeah and I know you don't think it's a
big deal either
but the first one is he's only five so I
remember when we took him when he was
four
everyone that was five that year I was
grateful that they were there because
they [__] had the five-year-old add
like they were like rolling all over the
place not paying attention like they
were running amok and I remember going
like oh thank God I'm not the only
parent with a [__] an uncivilized
[__] animal on the map yeah you know
so I felt really good then when they
started getting older now they're six
it's a whole different kid yeah or now
I'm looking at them and going okay maybe
I'll get there probably not the same way
because they are not diagnosed with ADHD
um but at least I know that there's some
maturing that happens so that's the
first thing that works against us is the
age the second one is that he's
Australian as you like to put it yeah
um yeah uh so that's also a thing
um I feel like right now he's at a stage
or at an age where he doesn't even know
what he really likes so I I try to push
him as hard as I
feel or think that is all right before
he gets to the point where he starts
hating [__] because he's only five I'll
tell you exactly what he likes and he
tell me where you should put him in okay
you ready yeah that's the [__] around
uh
um that doesn't every kid likes to [__]
around not more than him
okay I'll tell you his favorite obstacle
course you ready
you ready yeah
if we set up
30.
just glass windows in frames
and you give them rocks and he told them
you better break all these glass windows
with all these lonely rocks just laying
there
at the time of his [__] life I
thought you were gonna name something
that actually is a sport no well I'm
just telling you I'm going to color
outside of the lines too right because
that's who he is sports are created by
the right this is the path you put a
ball in this hole I put a ball in this
whole who gets more right it's so
structured so organized people that are
Australian with the tally whackers
hanging out they ain't doing that
we're wild boys right so wild boys gotta
do wild things the problem is there's
not that many wild things out there for
people to do yeah so for
um for someone like him I'm like he got
wild tendencies
what is something that you think would
be great for a wild boy what do I think
is something yeah because you know that
activity I just named yeah you know he's
gonna love it honestly what I think I
would put him in let's say I was a
sequel parent I would still keep him in
Jiu Jitsu yeah I would definitely keep
him in Jiu Jitsu because I feel like
just foundationally it's great yeah also
I love his coach and his coach teaches
him so much structure has the patience
is Stern but is very emotionally
intelligent and soft that
um I feel like it's molding him really
well so I would still keep him there if
that coach were to leave I either follow
that coach or he's not doing Jiu-Jitsu
anymore or I find someone that's that's
on par with his current coach uh the
other thing I'd probably put him in is
probably some type of like motorbike or
dirt bike or like biking type of Trail
because it's just it's an obstacle
course type of deal and there's like ups
and downs he gets to be out in nature so
you can't really [__] up a bunch of [__]
um and he's Racing for his life so I
think with that knowing what I know from
from what you've described about ADHD I
feel like would be something pretty
challenging for him where there's like
enough movement and like
um danger if you will but then there's
also like the time limit like there's
just so many things that he has to stay
focused on
for him to do well in let me ask you a
question you get on my dirt bike okay
well I'd start with a bike give him a
bike okay cool bike one of the coolest
colors the bike that he's been always
wanted okay
you put that there you want to ride this
or
you see this bottle of shampoo
we're going to dump this in that public
Fountain over there and it's going to
create a bunch of bubbles which one is
he going to pick well I have to get him
to the same level of understanding of
what happens once he tips the bottle
over right which bottle the shampoo that
yourself bottle of shampoo yes so I have
to get the same level of riding a bike
so he needs to understand how both
operate so he would need to know how to
ride a bike
I still feel like he'd pick the [__]
shampoo that's what I'm saying he's a
wild boy right so I'm like how do we
find the professional version
of that so I think the next Mr Beast I
think it's going to be the extreme
sports for now
right until he's old enough to invent
his own [__] or we're able to find
something that he can fit into because
that's that's his mind
his mind I think like
things that I think he can predict isn't
going to hit those like dopamine and
serotonin like endorphins in his brain
you know because for him he's not a say
it yet but I think people with ADHD it's
like oh that's [__] basic like what
like yeah you're just gonna ride it and
then go on the half pipe and then spin
around oh damn I'm such a normie you
know what I mean I was just thinking
like whoa that's perfect for something
great like you know all the stuff that I
just tossed out the trash the other day
Okay and all those are random pieces of
debris
that you that you picked out of the
backyard he brought those into our our
house what random pieces of like that
big round plastic blasting like he he
did goals and searches like his idea of
fun those are Treasures yeah exactly is
treasure hunting yeah so like
maybe I don't know maybe if we put two
and two together maybe he'd be like a
shipwreck diver or something because he
does like to swim yeah but I'm talking
about right now dude I know maybe we
gotta get him scuba certified early but
what I'm saying is
um that's his that's his thing right
like if you're aggressive maybe a combat
sport right if you're like that if you
you got hang time maybe you play
volleyball basketball or whatever right
his thing is Wild Boy like how do we
like is he a rodeo clown
barrel and spin around you know like
that's too basic like no what what is
I'm not gonna do this stud huh he's
gonna be the a [__] clown he could be
we could find a stud thing for him
what's the what's the the theme though
you know yeah
you know what I'm saying like that's
that's his true Essence and I think
what's cool like you're saying like
we've seen the most amount of
advancement from four and a half to five
so like I don't know if it's an event
advancement I'm just saying but we see
more of who he is yeah but if we can see
because I think there's like ADHD
and then there's who you are put
together is who like you will be right I
think if we can slowly like
um see who he is more and more
and then like add the two together
and then I think that way we can because
maybe right now it's it's like um the
exploration phases yeah we could be like
literally like Charles Darwin
you know in the Galapagos and we're
recognizing new species we don't know
it's mating rituals we barely know what
it eats we don't know it's lifestyle so
we're just trying our best like okay
this is a bird
so I think birds do this and it's not
until the bird grows up and we're like
oh this bird
doesn't fly or this bird is actually a
penguin it actually swims yeah
interesting so I feel like we just try
our best
and maybe right now it feels like
we're like getting our asses kicked but
I think as we are patiently trying to
see what this new species turns out to
we can finally see like okay this is
who he's supposed to be yeah so that's
what that's my optimistic way of hoping
we figure it out yeah but I think we're
doing a really good job like just me
comparing ourselves to a lot of our
parents and our peers
I'm like I think we actually care I mean
I'm sure everyone else cares too but
everyone else uh cares more in the
traditional sense
uh like the way that some of our friends
parents have raised them but I think we
actually like care and talk but then
also I don't know if like is that
backfiring you know
you came in so hot like we actually care
well because there's other parents that
are just like hey like that right hey
yeah yeah too we're go we go no they're
just like hey no Brad's watching
football
the [__] out of here bro uh kind of I
mean that's that's extreme but for us
we're more like hey like hey um like
Mama and Papa are having a serious
conversation like we do a lot of this
explanation [__] that a lot of parents I
noticed don't just like hey and the kids
oh [__] you know I don't know I mean
like we've always heard right like
there's no handbook to this [__] there
really is no right or wrong it's just
whatever fits
for you and your family with the
consideration of society yeah
and knowing that one day this kid is
gonna be an adult and a a contributor to
the society
so parents I feel like at least within
our Circle parents definitely care
they're just one they're dealing with a
different species yeah and a a more
average normal species
and um they just care in different ways
because they just have a different
outcome or goal for their kid
right so like uh some of my family
members like they're really strict to
just be like hey stop that right now no
explanation there's no talking back and
forth It's because they want their kid
to be what they view as you don't talk
back because that's disrespectful you
respect your elders there's a pecking
order like there's so many other rules
that are like
that they're following you don't think
they're after the same result we are
though
like we both want well-mannered kids of
course
of course but there's nothing I think
our explanations and stuff is actually
backfiring like helping him understand
it's actually backfiring versus these
are the rules and that's it well I think
I I mean maybe
I'll start with that possibly
but we're also pretty Keen to or just
we're also very much aware of who he is
in this phase at least where if he's
asking why we know he's not asking why
with attitude he's just genuinely
curious curious
he's not going like well why it's more
so like oh how come
right and we can because we were the how
come kids we were the black sheep of our
family we were the the variables we were
the not normies that we understand what
that means like we genuinely want to
understand so that we
don't have to ask why anymore and we can
move on with our life
so because we were those kids when we
see it in him or maybe that's an
insecurity of ours maybe we should have
been like stop it but we just saw that
didn't work for us
but yes why and then we tell them and
the next time you ask why again
yeah you can hear ourselves repeating
the same explanation at least a thousand
times so this is one thing that makes me
feel good is when he did get evaluated
with the doctor the behavioral
psychologist she did say that his his
communication skills are exceptional
exceptional yeah yeah like he's like so
they they rate it with um very poor poor
average
um what is it like high and then
exceptional or something like that when
it came to his communication and
emotional expression it was exceptional
I don't know what we did to get that
right to be honest this it's it's
talking it's actually engaging in a
conversation because what's happening is
we explain one the emotion and we get to
have a conversation to where now we're
explaining the vocabulary so you can use
the appropriate vocabulary to express
how he's feeling or just what he wants
to understand so instead of him lashing
on going ah ah and just yelling at a
very young age I was teaching him that
that feeling is frustration
so now instead of him going ah and then
just not knowing how to even communicate
that to us us getting upset control
yourself stop that right now you don't
do that that's bad him hitting things
and now thinking that there's some
behavioral [__] happening we just know
that he's five and he's feeling
frustration therefore we know how to
engage and deal with that and being like
hey that's okay we all get frustrated
okay what's making you frustrated and
now we can walk him through all of that
so now he can self-soothe and he can
express it to us and now we're all like
helping each other out so I think it's
because we talk to him that he's able to
now
you know Express himself uh self-soothe
communicate with others and now like it
just it everyone is like better than him
just like [__] throwing [__]
everywhere yeah you know I forgot what I
was telling them yesterday but I was
explaining something to him he goes oh I
didn't realize that yeah he says that
yeah
he'll say that well you know the words
that I choose is so funny it's funny but
it it's in the right context yeah right
because he doesn't say like we're not
like hey don't eat that nail yeah like
but the nail is I just realized you know
yeah yeah
like he'll just we're like don't eat it
you're gonna get sick oh I didn't
realize that I'd get sick yeah he's
really good at communication yeah and I
feel I I mean I could be wrong what the
[__] does anyone know right like we
don't really know but I have a huge
feeling that it's because we talked to
him and we engage in that conversation
and and although it's easier to be like
just do what I say stop it I don't want
to hear it you listen to me top down all
the time because we don't do that
constantly we definitely have our
moments but because we don't do that is
is is why he's able to have Stellar
communication and like emotional
understanding
but then there's times when I see him
with his nephews who are raised
definitely way more traditionally AKA
how I was raised they're definitely in
line and there's order and there's
structure
um parenting a lot more convenient
absolutely like when they're like need
to go on a trip all right let's go every
single kid files them pop pop seat belts
right and they're good yeah I don't know
what the hell Tak is doing he's like
going to his well he's shaking his hips
first his child seat backwards yep yeah
he's shaking his hips telling me if he
could bring his sunglasses to school
because the sun is drying his eyes yeah
yeah that was our conversation this
morning you know that
bring my sunglasses I was like no you
cannot he goes but the sun dries out my
eyes I'm like how does it dry your eyes
and I don't even know why I got sucked
into the conversation because you have
ADHD too maybe but I love him so much so
I was like how does this dry your eyes
and he goes well the sun's so hot isn't
it it is very hot but it's very far away
and then he was like oh yeah and then I
was like you know what you're doing your
eyes are dry I go what go you blink and
then it brings the tears back down and
moisturizes your eyes he goes oh oh
maybe that's what it was oh I didn't
realize that
that sounds like this so we do have a
lot of CUNY conversations but it took
all of that to get his butt in the
freaking car
yeah so
versus just like a normal pair like hey
get in the car you know her normal
parent doesn't necessarily have to have
anger issues they could just be like get
in the car it's not anger it's just
being honest I see I don't know shut up
is assertive
it could be more like hey get in the car
right now we gotta go you can be that I
see
um but the reason why I bring up my
nephews is
I know I have to stop doing this and
anytime I can catch myself doing this I
do like parent myself and be like hey
hey cut it out now is not comparing
taika to them
because that's not fair to taika right
but what I really do try to do is I try
to understand
The Goods the bads of that and I just
try to understand their structure and
and just kind of seeing what I can take
from that and then adapt it into my own
life
um so I definitely do catch myself like
when they're all together now me getting
a little bit more upset when he's not
listening or he's not following the
rules or he's not you know following
suit whenever when all the other kids
are doing that you know I am quicker to
be like hey what's happening and just
kind of like I'm doing a lot more
redirecting more often and I really do
try to be like wait but he's different
you know not in a good or not in a bad
way but it's just what applies to these
kids or that one particular kid does not
apply to my kid and I really really
really have to remind myself of that and
it's [__] hard
it's crazy because
um there's not many kids like him either
so sometimes it makes me feel like is he
wrong you know
like if there's a bunch of Australians
in his class
um oh yeah that's the Australian group
but there's also very few of them yeah
most kids there's some Dart exceptional
right line up boom all on the wall then
there's the ones that get there a little
bit later and then there's the other one
that's still like doing like jumping
jacks in the corner which is Tech or
whatever you know so I'm like
um he's such an outlier
that sometimes I don't know if it's on
the positive side of outlier like is he
the top one percent or is he the bottom
one percent yeah and that's the part
that's tricky you know yeah another
thing that I play around with a lot and
I kind of just even struggle with
sometimes is I tell myself who cares
he's five
and the and the struggle comes from me
going I've never lived on this planet
the way a 90 of the population lives on
this planet I don't make decisions the
same way ninety percent of the people do
like I don't have the same thought
process
um
so why am I trying to make my kid
fit into that mold I think because we're
trying to also integrate them into
system absolutely absolutely right yeah
but then I forget that I was never even
really integrated into the society yeah
you are
um you don't go to the airport and go
bomb everyone there's a [__] bomb
good part where I um that's why I
brought up he's only five who cares
because he's only five yeah I mean you
don't think if we don't stop him now
he's not he's gonna try to sneak smoke
bombs into the airport when he's 12.
I think there's age-appropriate like
conversations and and like discipline
and and like rules and guidelines and
stuff like that
um that's right now and he's our only
one like would we be this way if he was
number three or number four
so that's what I was thinking if it was
three or four maybe we'd revert to more
traditional parenting and do that hey
you know no talking
shut up you know like hey papa just like
this we're kind of experimenting just
more of the pop pop style because you
don't have time right yeah conduct the
whole class like everyone eat and but
why is it dry my eyes if you don't got
time for that that makes sense you got
four of them so maybe we are [__] up
maybe we're giving too much attention as
backfiring yeah maybe but then also
maybe that's why his his uh
communication also phenomenal yeah
because how many other five-year-olds
are saying like I didn't realize that
yeah
it's really hard but but say your first
kid is definitely the experimental one
because not to compare but him and his
cousins he talks circles around them
so they're bilingual but in terms of
communication though is I see I see
you're right you know I mean like
language is the platform but his ability
to articulate right Concepts you know
why is is insane it is so like that's
the double-edged sword we're like are we
is it backfiring because in one area he
is superb yeah based off a behavior
psychologist but in the other area takes
30 minutes for me to put on a seat belt
yeah
uh we could be for sure like we're not
going to be perfect I don't feel like I
feel like there's levers right like all
these levers they they're either up or
down
that I feel like it's like this like and
I think that's normal you know you're
not going to be perfect at every single
aspect of raising a kid
or helping mold the kid so
um it just depends on what's important
to us so for me what's important to me
is that he he understands or he knows
how to learn so for him I want him to
know how to learn I want him to know how
to learn how to be independent and how
to be polite
oh and an emotion I want him to
emotionally be mature
um and emotionally mature to me doesn't
mean like you mask your emotions and
you're always like this [__] stoic it
just means that you understand what
you're feeling and you act accordingly
or you like problem solve accordingly so
those are my important things
so if that's and again I have to remind
myself of these things because when I am
getting caught up in the moment and
going like [__] like why is he so
[__] difficult you know I have to
kind of go back and be like oh right but
like is this does this you know is this
like hiccup or whatever
a big deal in the grand scheme of what
I'm trying to teach this kid
it's [__] hard
it's pretty hard
it's [__] hard it's [__] hard
because it's yeah you
you get to see other parents other kids
and and you can't help but to kind of
compare but with the nephews that you
know that you're saying taika can talk
circles around
not just the nephews but everyone has
age you can talk circles around yeah
kind of but I've noticed that's a that's
a very specific trait for uh only
children that are around their parents a
lot yeah well because they're just
engaged or involved in a lot of adult
conversations
because they they're communicating with
adults all the time and adults don't
necessarily talk like kids adults talk
like adults kids because I've witnessed
that with just even a ton of white kids
they have like three or four siblings
and they all are just really articulate
a little age
maybe it's just I wasn't around a lot of
white kids so maybe that's what it is
that just is a different
um caliber of parent I guess
because that was even something as a kid
you know someone comes they use all
kinds of vocabulary like man I'll speak
White oh so it just meant that
articulate they're just smarter than you
yeah that's [__] funny yeah because
people come look like like all like well
excuse me according to whatever I'm like
may I speak waifu
you know that's CUNY that's CUNY uh that
it's just we're so stupid to even use
that term yeah to be make it like
they're smarter but they're it's more
derogatory yeah yeah yeah it's like no
you're just basically saying you're
stupid it has nothing to do with it
doesn't be a nerdy Asian kid you know
coming in well actually yesterday I went
to whatever whatever man you're white
get out of here that shows how ghetto we
[__] grew up yeah yeah we're [__]
ghetto I don't know whatever it is that
we're doing
I don't know I I just I'm like it just
I'm just gonna keep trying my best
I'm gonna keep trying my best just
trying to remind myself that I want him
to what is your best though like what's
your like
North Star my North Stars those things
that I talked about right like I want
him to be able to learn like know the
process of learning so that he can be
put into any situation and he can like
decode or whatever right so I really
want him to to to know that and have
like a thirst for that to be like I
don't understand something let me try to
understand it like I really do like that
the independence part of it because he's
not going to be a baby forever he is
going to grow up and and you know he
might live on his own or like I just
don't want him to to be coddled in any
sort of way like I want him to be very
independent it's very empowering at
least I feel like it's very empowering
obviously half manners
um because he's not better than anyone
no one's better than him but he's not
better than anyone so I want him to to
be respectful
um take care of us take care of his
family his friends and by taking care I
don't mean like like literally take care
but always have their back and that
loyalty and all that stuff
um uh what was my fourth one so it's a
learning manners Independence
um [__] I forgot the fourth one right
now was that one like that was like
dealing with his emotions in a healthy
way or something oh yeah yeah
and then and if you can understand your
emotions then I feel like you can
navigate life better
that's one thing that's like this is
very extreme and very very sad to say
but I think that is like single-handedly
what would prevent a lot of school
shootings
emotional maturity yeah I think that's
one of one of the things that like
um statistically a lot of like the mass
shootings like even the one recently in
like Monterey Park it's usually a
disenfranchised family so that dude the
guy he's like 70. you can tell that like
um even at his age he still needs a
sense of belonging by the time that he
uh committed that crime
his family kind of abandoned him so he
was living um I think in a trailer park
in one of those small cities in
California no one knows about Hemet or
something
so his kids don't want him his uh his
his wife or whatever don't want him he
got kicked out of that dance studio and
that's like the same although it's like
a very asian-centric thing because you
think about like Asian uh perpetrator in
the Asian Community but that's like the
same thing as like white perpetrator and
white Community you know and it's
usually like a father figure and not
there people don't understand them or
whatever like that and then so that's
people have unhealthy ways of coping
with emotions yeah because either one
they haven't been brought up to digest
and work through them and it just
becomes this big thing where the action
that they commit doesn't really match
the feelings that they feel yeah yeah
you know like the girl that doesn't want
to go on a date with you doesn't mean
you go and hurt 30 people yeah you know
and so I think that part is actually
extremely important where um
uh hearing you say that makes me feel
good because I think that's something
that especially with the so onset of
social media like the minute kids are on
social media now the emotions that
they're experiencing is tremendous yeah
well this guy's more beautiful than me
this guy's stronger than me this guy's
richer than me this guy's a better life
than me and you have these crazy
emotions that you didn't really
necessarily feel as a kid I remember as
a kid it's just like oh Tommy got a new
bike oh that's pretty cool I wish I had
a new bike and that's it it's not Tommy
got a new like Peter got a new like Mike
got a new bike you know it's like and uh
to be able to work through those
emotions I think is going to be
something that's going to be really
important for him yeah absolutely
um I feel like that saved me from one it
got me into a lot of trouble not being
emotionally mature
um and then it also when I was able to
get a little bit more mature with it I
was able to get out of a lot of trouble
or prevent myself from getting into that
trouble so that's why for me it's it's
something that's super important but
what was your question that you were
asking that made me go into that you're
like what is my North yeah what is your
North Star with him yeah but you
answered it oh well yeah it's those four
like my four pillars if you will
with him but uh I just want to make sure
that I understand him yeah
yeah so above all like I just my role as
a mom is obviously to stick to my four
pillars for his sake but for our
relationship's sake with me and him
um and so that I can stick to these four
pillars and like really give them the
tools to stick to that is me really
trying really hard to understand who he
is
and right now he's just changing so
[__] much that I'm like oh [__] I'm
just trying to keep up
I think I really understand him I mean
my job is uh
how do I integrate him into society like
he's a [__] like he's just like this
like you're trying to rehabilitate a
[__] wild Savage like honestly if
tomorrow I was like hey let's go on a
hike okay whatever well let's go to
other arcades oh that's pretty fun I'm
like hey Papa's idea well you already
presented it differently no no I know
because you say because it's it's his
because I already know what it is yeah
but if you go Papa has an idea I'm
already in but let's go to an arcade
sounds boring but if you go I have an
idea what if we go to the arcade like oh
okay that's pretty cool okay but if I
was like Papa's idea we're gonna get 20
bottles of shampoo and we're gonna go
every single public Fountain we're gonna
pour it in and then we're gonna run to
the side I'm gonna hide behind the bush
and see what people say he's gonna a lot
of people want to do that I'm down to do
that that sounds [__] fun most people
are like I don't know if we should
right most people have like those
inhibitions they're like yeah because
they're integrated into [__] society
yeah but if you turn that off everyone
wants to do that but they also have the
Consciousness or or or they understand
the consequences of if a happens B
happens this is gonna be the [__]
result
so I think that's what stops them but if
we we eliminated the consequences
everyone would be like I'm [__] down
or maybe I'm also [__] weird that his
dream toys probably people haven't even
invented yet yeah like if someone got
him like you know those sticky hand
that's like this and you can stick stuff
if we get a life-size one that's 30 feet
long
yeah I mean and we can like throw it out
poor Mia yeah and it just pulls it back
you would have a blast so would I can
someone invent that please like that's
what that's the kind of stuff he wants
and he needs and I can tell because his
brain works like mine oh my [__] God
all right like if I told them hey
tomorrow we're gonna give me a hairstyle
with gel and hairspray who [__] love
it
what else are we doing he would love it
oh my God that's why I told you remember
uh because you know you're gonna be gone
this weekend uh and I told you I already
have an idea that I think he would love
remember what I said with the idea list
no so I'm gonna have him draw oh right
right whatever he wants on paper
and as ridiculous as it is if it's like
a house with a grapefruit or a [__]
can you please Vlog this yes I will with
the hanger on it
whatever it is when he draws it we're
gonna go to a Home Depot or wherever we
need to go to buy all the parts to build
it
so if he wants to paint it we could
paint it I'm going to do exactly and I
think he's gonna have a
super fun time it's [__] red okay
well I can't wait to see what that all
looks like okay on that note if you're a
parent who's absolutely [__] lost and
doesn't know what the [__] is going on
with parenting but you're trying your
[__] best
good on you because that's all we could
[__] do so we see you hard-working
parents
we're with you we're together on this
[__] we're gonna have amazing kids
they're gonna be amazing contributors to
this Society just keep trying your best
and we'll just [__] cross off our
fingers and if you're one of those
parents
and you don't have to do anything and
your kids are Stellar
you're God's chosen you got five kids
and it takes zero work to raise them and
they raise themselves [__] you
[__] oh my God okay on that note
have a good day we'll see you guys soon
uh next week before we end
podcast is brought to you by Barlow
Brigade yeah you're One Stop Shop for
dope Fitness [__] and I say dope Fitness
themes because there's a ton of Fitness
Brands out there but we spend the extra
time to make everything sick from the
best tasting supplements that are
effective to dope gear there's teasing
them rocking with always dope STEEZ
because it's not about just training
it's about training looking cool about
the culture and then also uh training
programs that are highly effective that
are easy to follow for all of your dope
training needs go to Barber brigade.com
see you guys next time